et ce constat ce sont les grands parents
qui s'occupent des petits enfants voilà
pendant ces vacances parce qu
apparemment beaucoup de parents
travaillent oui voilà combien
ça fait rigoler en région nous dit ça
sent du vécu
et oui alors au musée de la ville vous
propose également des ateliers pour les
enfants dites-nous je crois qu'il y en a
cinq ou six oui on assiste effectivement
sur ces quinze jours de vacances donc du
mercredi au samedi à 16 heures un
atelier différent chaque jour donc nous
aussi on accueille des parents et des
grands parents aujourd'hui j'ai animé un
atelier avec deux grands mères et leurs
petits-enfants donc on n'échappe pas à
la règle nous on propose des ateliers
ludiques et pédagogiques autour d'eux
des patrimoines et puis de tout ce qui
se fait en ville donc l'art dans la
ville les matériaux de construction
l'idée c'est que les enfants puissent se
glisser dans la peau de métiers
différents de l'urbaniste à l'artiste en
passant par bah celui qui fait le béton
et qui construit les les immeubles et
les logements peut vraiment repartir
avec un échantillon de daf et je vous ai
amené un petit échantillon fédé presse
papier en béton donc voilà c'est passé
voilà l'apprentissage de tout ça en fait
du dessin de la ville aux réalisations
les plus concrètes d'accord donc
globalement donc on a un atelier
chouette la ville a rétréci le 16 le
pardon le 7 c'est l'art et le mouvement
ce salon qui a une ateliers et un
atelier et en même temps d'exposition
parallèle oui en fait donc effectivement
il ya une exposition au musée en ce
moment qui s'appelle rêvons la ville et
qui d'ailleurs si vous n'avez pas vu
ferme le 16 mars au soir donc
profitez-en même si vous n'avez pas
envie de pratiquer en famille avec les
ateliers vous pouvez venir vos balais
dans l'exposition et autour de cette
exposition sur la ville il ya toutes
sortes d'ateliers qui cette exposition
ferme parce que vous fermez vous même
mais ferme voilà pendant un petit mois
un bon mois plus tôt pour démonter et
remonter la prochaine exposition du
musée qui sera sur le plastique donc
donc voilà faut en profiter pendant ces
quinze jours pour les rallier
presse-papier en plastique ce sera
différent est ce que vous êtes
continuellement
ce sera des sièges a fabriqué en
plastique il varie beaucoup d'idées
cadeaux pour les fêtes des pères et des
mères
oui nous le principe c'est que les
enfants puissent à chaque fois il ya
toujours une partie de découverte soit
l'exposition soit une oeuvre d'art dans
là ville ou pour le béton va toucher
aussi on va se balader un petit pot tour
du zèle vie des arts et patrimoine voilà
nous c'est vraiment qu'il découvre à la
fois leur environnement les techniques
les métiers et aussi qui passe après à
la pratique donc il ya toujours ce
double regard de découverte et ensuite
de pratiques soi-même pour fabriquer une
oeuvre d'art une maquette un échantillon
de béton presse papier voilà il ya bien
deux et pour toutes les dates on laisse
nos téléspectateurs se reporter à notre
site internet tout est simple parce
qu'il ya plus sincères et 16 heures du
mercredi au samedi ensuite pour
l'atelier correspondant à quelques jours
vous pouvez venir nous voir notre site
internet ou appelez au musée on vous
répond avec plaisir et on vous explique
un petit peu plus en détail chaque
atelier parfait merci beaucoup même
question juste que la ferme de gally sur
la fréquentation ça a plutôt bien marché
sur les ailes où démarre aujourd'hui
cela vous démarrez pendant les vacances
à sa fonction bas les vacances de
février oui on reçoit quand même pas mal
de public ça fonctionne assez bien
effectivement sur beaucoup
d'intergénérationnel
des centres de loisirs aussi qui
viennent pas mal nous voir donc là il y
avait trois familles tout à l'heure pour
l'atelier donc nous on est un petit
musée donc on aime aussi ce côté
proximité où les enfants puissent et que
les enfants puissent échanger entre eux
sur wiiz habite quelles oeuvres d'art et
le bâtiment à côté de chez eux et c'est
donc c'est des petits groupes mais c'est
pour le coup du coup très agréable de
faire les ateliers c'est toujours
intéressant de voir comment les saint
quentinois les yvelinois s'approprient
les activités qui sont qui sont proposés
on a entendu tout à l'heure avec le
micro-trottoir merci donc à tous les
trois avec les différents rendez-vous
qui sont proposés de quoi vous occuper
pendant les prochains jours